-You look great, buddy.
You look sharp.
It's great to see you, pal.
-How's it going?
-How you doing?
It's going great.
You've had a lot
going on these past few months.
You released your new album
in September.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
Number one. Not too shabby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You also recently announced
that you had another child.
Congratulations!
-Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
-Your kids are actually heard
in the intro of the album.
-Yes. Yes.
And, uh, I --
Well, my 4-month was like
sort of a subliminal message.
I didn't just reveal it.
You know, and most of my fans,
I would say a good portion did
not pick up on the heartbeat.
-Well, I don't know
how you would guess.
Did people actually guess that
the heartbeat is your new baby?
-I do have some fans.
-One person here recognized it.
You knew that?
-"That's a baby!"
-Yeah, that's -- I mean --
Well, listen.
Listen to -- The other --
Your other children speak.
You'll hear after --
After you hear "Dada," listen.
[ Child fusses ]
Dada!
[ Heart beating ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now --
Do you have kids?
-Yes, I do.
-Have kids. Okay.
Maybe you could
give me some advice.
My 4-year-old, Valentino --
You know how there's
a philosophy that kids
are a product
of their environment?
-Yeah.
-That's not necessarily true.
You know, our household,
nothing but love, great energy.
And he's extremely misbehaved.
[ Laughter ]
Like -- But, you know,
we get complaints from school.
He has this infamous line.
He's like, "Yo no quiero tu,"
which means, "I don't want you."
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- it's pretty bad.
It's pretty bad.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
-He's gonna be fine.
He's got you as a dad.
Come on, bud.
Can we talk about --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The "Fórmula" albums.
They're fantastic.
The last one was on
the Billboard charts for
400-and-something -- 420 weeks
or something crazy.
-Yeah, something like that.
-Is that unbelievable?
You got "Vol. 3."
Great collaborations.
I don't want to name names,
but Justin Timberlake.
Whatever.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I --
What was Justin like?
-Oh, man. What an experience.
A great experience.
I could tell you that prior
to showing him the record,
I thought he was just going to
lay down vocals, you know,
probably change
a few verses, melodies.
This guy just, you know,
dissected the song
and reproduced it
and was telling me
how to sing the song,
and he made it much better.
So he's --
-He's kind of amazing.
-A true producer.
-He's a magician, right?
-He goes, "No, do that
and do that."
I mean, we've done bits
with him on the show,
and, yeah, he's a --
he's a perfectionist.
-Shout-out to J.T.
Golf champion Justin Timberlake.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll tell you...
Also, there's some -- there's
some great comedians.
Katt Williams.
-Yes.
-Why did you decide
to put comedians on the album?
-I mean, it's just, uh...
It's -- I love comedy.
-Yeah.
-I wanted to make it
very personal.
I started
with "Fórmula, Vol. 1."
I had George Lopez,
"Vol. 2," I had Kevin Hart.
I just wanted to continue
with the same concept.
-Yeah. Is this the
last of the "Fórmula" albums,
or will there be a "Fórmula" --
-Hell yeah, hell yeah,
hell yeah.
This is --
[ Laughter ]
You know, my fans, if I have any
fans in the audience...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Listen, you guys enjoy
the albums, and, you know,
the support is amazing.
I respect that you embrace me
the way you do,
but a lot of work
goes into this.
[ Laughter ]
And it's very stressful.
-But I mean, I'm saying,
"Fórmula," if there is
a "Vol. 4," there's --
there's other comedians
out there that would love --
-No, Sure. But a lot of work
goes into this.
-I understand a lot of work,
but it's not that hard.
You know, when you get
the right --
you get the right comedian,
get in there, you're in and out.
People want to see it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, I do want to ask you,
because you're very --
always been great to us
and very nice to us
and very humbled
and have a great team,
as well, when you come.
We love everybody here.
But how do you do that
when you sell out
Yankee Stadium and stuff?
I mean, that's insane.
-You know, there's a lot of,
like, prep and --
and, you know, orchestrating,
like, these type of shows
so you don't get to
really, like --
you're not, you know,
on stage like,
"Oh, I sold this out.
Wow. 60,000 --"
Doesn't work that way, you know?
-No.
But do you miss New York
when you go on the road?
-I do very much.
Very much.
-Yeah. What's -- What's --
What things
of New York do you really miss?
-This is going to sound funny,
but the food, you know?
I love the food.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I love Chinese food.
And my issue is that they don't
have the same duck sauce
that we have here in New York.
[ Laughter ]
They don't. They don't.
-In the packets?
-So I travel
with my own duck sauce.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You travel
with your own duck sauce.
-Like, I'm not --
I'm not kidding.
Like, this is real [bleep]
you know?
[ Laughter ]
I'm ready.
-So, this is --
You get th--
This is the real duck sauce
that you get from
your favorite Chinese restaurant
here in New York City?
-Yes.
-And you travel with it.
You actually have
a bag backstage,
a ziplock bag,
full of duck sauce.
-This is true.
I'm not making this up.
I like to travel with my own
duck sauce and my own ketchup.
-And your own ketchup.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I love that you travel
with the duck sauce.
I just figured, since you're on
your world tour right now,
you are bringing it
to the States, as well,
back to America...
-Yes, yes.
-...I wanted to make sure
that you're going to be okay.
So, we actually got you
a giant basket.
full of duck sauce here.
This is for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Romeo Santos, everybody!
"Fórmula, Vol. 3" is available
right now!
Romeo's performing
for us after the break.
Come on back, everybody.